Welcome to ADSP The Podcast, welcome to adsp the podcast episode 87 recorded on june 24 2022 my name is connor and today with my co-host bryce we finish part four of our four-part interview with tony van eerd so my sister had a had a a dog like that australian sheep dog or whatever super smart right super smart dog yeah they're very smart dogs and friendliest dog in the world you know and then i go over to my sister's house one day and nobody you know i you know knock on the back door and it's like doesn't seem like anyone's home or whatever and i think i was dropping something off or something so i just like open up the back door and i'm like hey is anyone home today and everything right and i'm looking around and i was like i'll just i'll just put this thing on this
欢迎来到 ADSP 播客，欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 87 期，录制于 2022 年 6 月 24 日。我是康纳（Connor），今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯（Bryce）将完成我们对托尼·范埃德（Tony Van Eerd）四部分访谈的第四部分。所以我的姐姐养了一只那样的狗，澳大利亚牧羊犬什么的，超级聪明，对吧？超级聪明的狗。是的，它们是非常聪明的狗，而且是世界上最友好的狗，你知道的。然后有一天我去我姐姐家，没有人，你知道，我敲了敲后门，好像没有人在家或者什么的，我想我当时是去送点东西什么的，所以我只是打开了后门，然后我说，嘿，今天有人在家吗？诸如此类的话。我四处看了看，心想，我把这东西放在这个
table or whatever and then i noticed the dog is not barking and trying to like protect the house the dog is trying to sneak up on me it's just like coming i saw it sneak around a corner and then it's just like backed away a little bit and it's like the dog was like i'm like this dog knows me it should be it should be you know hey hey tony blah blah blah and wagging its tail it's like no right now it is in protection she was flanking you yeah yeah like totally this dog loony is uh is a very smart dog and uh yeah and she like she loves toys she's not food motivated at all she loves toys but toys are not fun for her unless like the humans are playing with with the toys too like it has to be interactive and uh and like she's yeah she's pretty she's pretty smart like like a ball gets
桌子上或者什么的，然后我注意到那只狗没有叫，也没有试图保护房子，那只狗正试图悄悄靠近我，它就像是在走过来，我看到它鬼鬼祟祟地绕过一个拐角，然后它就稍微退后了一点，那感觉就像那狗在说——我觉得这只狗认识我，它应该，它应该——你知道的，“嘿，嘿，托尼，巴拉巴拉，”然后摇着尾巴。结果并没有，此时此刻它处于保护状态。它在侧翼包抄你。是的，是的，完全如此。这只狗露尼（Loony）是一只非常聪明的狗，而且，是的，它喜欢玩具，它对食物一点也不感兴趣，它喜欢玩具，但是玩具对它来说一点也不好玩，除非人类也和它一起玩玩具——它必须是互动的。而且，是的，它非常聪明，就像一个球掉到了
like under like a table or something she knows how to how to get the ball out from under the table i had a dog who figured out how to how to open the door in the barn because like one way you just push the door open it was like just the door in the barn that didn't have a doorknob so it had a string tied to it that like through the whole like you could just pull it open and stuff and so this dog figured out one way you push the door open and the other way like grab the the string the rope on the door and pull it open and it could open the door by itself i was like really cool smart dog do you think i could do you think i could teach the dog to do it on command like i'm carrying something hey dog open the door like we're standing the dog like would stare at me he's like why aren't we opening the door i'm like my hands are full yeah smart dog but i don't know we had a dog that could play the piano that's nice i mean
桌子下面或者什么地方，它知道怎么把球从桌子底下弄出来。我以前有一只狗，它学会了如何打开谷仓的门，因为其中一个方向你只需把门推开就行了，那是谷仓里唯一没有门把手的门，所以它上面绑了一根绳子，你可以把它拉开。所以这只狗学会了，一个方向你把门推开，另一个方向抓住门上的绳子把它拉开，它就能自己开门了。我当时想，真是太酷、太聪明的狗了。你觉得我能，你觉得我能教这狗按指令开门吗？就像我拿着东西的时候说：“嘿，狗，开门。”我们就站在那儿，那狗盯着我，好像在说：“我们为什么不开门？”我说：“我的手占着呢。”是的，是一只聪明的狗，不过我不知道，我们曾有一只会弹钢琴的狗。那挺不错的，我是说
didn't play it well but he played the piano we had it we had a a parrot that could ride a horse well okay i mean i'm sure there's plenty of animals that you could put on the horse but like no like control the horse well this is this is the thing so if you if you're in the in the horse world right um you go to the horse shows and they have all these contests that horse you do with your horse and one of them is is to run the barrels right you have to there's some barrels set up on the corral thing that you're doing this in you have to run you have to ride the horse as fast as you can around the barrels. You have to do a certain pattern. You have to turn the right direction, do it the right pattern, and come back. And it's who can do it the fastest.
弹得不是很好，但他弹了钢琴。我们有一只，我们有一只会骑马的鹦鹉。好吧，我的意思是，我确信有很多动物你可以把它们放到马上去，但是——不，是控制那匹马。好吧，这就是重点，所以如果你，如果你在马术界，对吧，你去参加马术秀，他们有各种各样的比赛，你要和你的马一起完成，其中一项就是绕桶赛，对吧？你必须——有一些桶设置在你正在进行的畜栏里，你必须尽可能快地骑着马绕过这些桶。你必须按照特定的路线完成。你必须向正确的方向转弯，按正确的路线完成，然后回来。看谁能最快完成。
It's the same with catching a steer and all these other things they do in these horse shows and stuff. Dying to know the connections to the parrot. Go on. So my dad taught the parrot to ride the horse to do the barrels. So no one on the horse, the horse would do the barrels, the right pattern correctly. And it was like a complicated pattern. And come back and my dad was like, look, I trained this parrot to ride a horse. Really, he trained the horse. The parrot just sat there.
抓住小牛和其他所有他们在这些马术秀里做的事情也是一样的。迫不及待地想知道这和鹦鹉有什么联系。说下去吧。所以我的爸爸教鹦鹉骑马去绕桶。所以马背上没有人，马会去绕桶，正确地走完正确的路线。而且那是一个复杂的路线。然后回来，我爸爸就说：“看，我训练了这鹦鹉骑马。”实际上，是他在训练马。鹦鹉只是坐在那里。
He trained the parrot to not fly away and trained a horse to run the barrels by itself. So, yeah, that's what we do. I have no idea at this point what I'm going to be calling these episodes. If we could just brainstorm for a second here. Did you want to talk about C++ ever in this episode at all? We did talk a little bit. Cancer, dismemberment.
他训练鹦鹉不飞走，并训练马自己去绕桶。所以，是的，这就是我们所做的。我此时完全不知道我要把这些节目叫什么名字。如果我们能在这里头脑风暴一下的话。你在这期节目里到底还想不想聊 C++？我们确实聊了一点。癌症，肢解。
Cancer dismemberment in horses. I think it's going to be like Tony's career. Tony's dad. Tony's dad's finger. I don't know. No. Tony's parrot.
马身上的癌症和肢解。我想这期标题会是：托尼的职业生涯。托尼的爸爸。托尼爸爸的手指。我不知道。不。托尼的鹦鹉。
And the thing is Tony has plenty tony has plenty of like amazing awesome tech stories but tony also has plenty of crazy life stories yeah it's true one one thing now well because we're a few minutes over but um no one's been saying they have to exit you say a few minutes over you say that as if there is like a set agenda or schedule for when we record. I mean, you booked a 90-minute time slot, and we are over that 90 minutes. And Tony probably does need to go back to his family at some point. Forget Tony. I got to go, like, cook.
关键是，托尼有很多，托尼有很多精彩绝伦的科技故事，但托尼也有很多疯狂的生活故事。是的，确实如此。现在有一件事——好吧，因为我们已经超了几分钟，但是——没有人在说他们必须离开。你说了“超了几分钟”，你这话听起来好像我们记录的时间有什么既定的议程或日程表似的。我的意思是，你预订了 90 分钟的时间段，而我们已经超过了那 90 分钟。而且托尼可能确实需要在某个时候回到他的家人身边。忘掉托尼吧。我得去，比如，做饭。
Oh, yeah. Bryce's food. That sounds more important than family. It's not my food. I got to cook for the... My family is full grown now. As my girlfriend likes to say, the division of labor is I cook, she eats. Question. So you were in Windsor. Did you go to Waterloo and your family still stayed in Windsor?
哦，对。布莱斯的食物。听起来比家人还重要。这不是我的食物。我得给……我的家人现在已经完全长大了。正如我女友喜欢说的，分工是我做饭，她吃。问题来了。所以你曾在温莎。你去滑铁卢了，而你的家人还是留在温莎吗？
We moved out of Windsor when I was eight or nine, which still didn't get me to Waterloo. It got me to a town called Bothwell. Bothwell? Yeah, it's like a thousand people. It's between London and Chatham for those people who know. Never even heard of Chatham either. I've heard of London, definitely.
我八九岁的时候搬出了温莎，但这还是没把我带到滑铁卢。它把我带到了一个叫博斯韦尔（Bothwell）的小镇。博斯韦尔？是的，那里大约有一千人。对于那些知道的人来说，它在伦敦和查塔姆之间。甚至都没听说过查塔姆。我绝对听说过伦敦。
So, okay, it's between London and Windsor. Put it that way. There we go. That's London, Canada, folks, just in case we're a little confused there. Yeah, like both London and Windsor. Put it that way. There we go. That's London, Canada folks, just in case we're a little. Yeah. Like both London and Windsor are like in Chatham. Those are all,
所以，好吧，它在伦敦和温莎之间。这么说吧。就是这样。各位，那是加拿大的伦敦，以防我们有点糊涂。是的，就像伦敦和温莎都在查塔姆。这些全部都是，
uh, uh, England, uh, towns. Yeah. Cause you know, people came over here,
呃，呃，英格兰的，呃，城镇。是的，因为你知道，人们来到这里，
had no, um, creativity. Um, and so this is kind of a funny thing that I, uh, so I grew up in a small town outside of, you know, left Windsor, rest of my childhood is in a small town and in a log house instead of, in Windsor, we had
毫无，呃，创造力。呃，所以这其实是一件挺有趣的事，我，呃——所以我是在（离开温莎后）外面一个小镇长大的，你知道，离开了温莎，我的其余童年都是在一个小镇里度过的，住在一栋圆木房子里，而在温莎，我们有
a writing stable and people all the time. Instead, we like lived in the middle of nowhere. And then I went off to high school. And I remember in grade nine, in in high school I wanted to be an architect right because um I actually did art um I've always I've always drawn and stuff like that um like my my high school art teacher was distraught when I didn't go to art school like she wanted me to go to uh Ontario College of Art and I'm like I'm gonna take math and physics she's like what why why would you do this I'm like I like math and physics. She's like, what? Why? Why would you do this? And I'm like, I like math and physics.
一个马术俱乐部，人们一直都在。相反，我们就像是住在荒郊野岭。然后我上了高中。我记得在九年级的时候，在高中里，我想成为一名建筑师，对吧？因为，呃——我其实学过美术，我一直、一直都在画画之类的，呃——比如我的高中美术老师在我没有去美术学院时感到非常沮丧，她希望我去，呃，安大略艺术学院，而我说我要去学数学和物理，她说：“什么？你为什么要做这个？”我说：“我喜欢数学和物理。”她说：“什么？为什么？你为什么要做这个？”我说：“我喜欢数学和物理。”
But if you're good at art and you like math and physics, architect is a great job. It fits everything. And I like being outdoors. And I figured as an architect, you would sometimes be out on site. And you wouldn't be. I was like, I'd never want to have a job where I sit behind a desk all day and stuff like that. That's, you know, I grew up in the, in the country.
但是如果你擅长美术，又喜欢数学和物理，建筑师就是一个很棒的职业。它符合所有的条件。而且我喜欢待在户外。我想象着作为一名建筑师，你有时会去工地现场。而你其实并不会。我当时想，我绝不想找一份整天坐在办公桌后面的工作之类的事。那是，你知道的，我在乡下长大。
I want to, want to stay there. Right. Um, and so, and then in grade nine, I looked up, where would you go to school for architecture? Right. And the, in Canada, the best place to go is Waterloo. It's, it's the architecture school, right? I did not know that. And in grade nine, I looked that up, and I said,
我想，想要留在那里。对吧。呃，所以，然后在九年级的时候，我查了一下，你在哪里可以去上建筑学学校？对吧。而在加拿大，最好的去处就是滑铁卢。那是，那是建筑学院，对吧？我当时并不知道。而在九年级的时候，我查了那个，我说，
Waterloo, and that's like two hours away from home, and I was like, that's too far. I don't want to go that far from home. And I just dropped it out of my brain. I'm like, I'm not going to be an architect. And then eventually, I ended up living in Waterloo. I ended up going to school up here. And then eventually I ended up living in Waterloo. I ended up going to school up here, and then I just stayed up here.
滑铁卢，离家大约有两个小时的车程，我当时想，太远了。我不想离家那么远。然后我就把它从我的脑子里抹掉了。我想，我不会成为一名建筑师了。然后最终，我还是在滑铁卢生活了。我最后来到这里上学。然后最终我还是在滑铁卢生活了。我最后来到这里上学，然后我就一直呆在这里了。
Wait, you did go to Waterloo though, right? I actually went to Laurier, the tiny high school down the road from Waterloo. I always thought you went to Waterloo. I took courses at Waterloo as well, and courses in Guelph. I kept taking courses after I graduated. I took courses at Waterloo as well, and courses in Guelph. I kept taking courses after I graduated.
等等，不过你确实去过滑铁卢，对吧？我实际上去的是劳里埃（Laurier），滑铁卢路边的那所小型高中。我一直以为你上的是滑铁卢。我也在滑铁卢上过课，还在圭尔夫（Guelph）上过课。我毕业后一直在上课。我也在滑铁卢上过课，还在圭尔夫上过课。我毕业后一直在上课。
For all of our American listeners, these are places in Canada that I know. Well, so Waterloo, everyone in programming should know about Waterloo because it really is a top programming school. It's a top 10 CS school. At least it was last time i checked and and people that go there like to say it's the harvard of canada which it is it's good no no if you had said that i would have made fun of you and i would have made fun of waterloo and i would have made fun of harvard yeah it is a very i wouldn't say it's harvard ivy league status but like it is a very, very good school.
对于我们所有的美国听众来说，这些都是我知道的加拿大地方。好吧，所以滑铁卢，每个搞编程的人都应该知道滑铁卢，因为它确实是一所顶尖的编程学校。这是一所排名前 10 的计算机科学学校。至少在我上次查看时是这样的，而且去那里的人喜欢说它是加拿大的哈佛，确实如此，它很好。不，不，如果你当时这么说，我就会取笑你了，我也会取笑滑铁卢，我还会取笑哈佛。是的，它是一所非常——我不会说它是哈佛常春藤盟校的地位，但它确实是一所非常非常好的学校。
Yeah. For programming, it is. I mean, it's where I get all my interns. We constantly have interns from there. That's where I get them. Their co-op program is phenomenal. And they also run a series of math contests through high school. And if you place in the top 10% or 5% or something, you get automatic admission and access to like an honors program.
是的。对于编程来说，确实如此。我的意思是，我所有的实习生都是从那里找的。我们源源不断地从那里招收实习生。这就是我招募他们的地方。他们的合作教育（co-op）项目非常出色。而且他们还通过高中举办了一系列数学竞赛。如果你名列前 10% 或 5% 或类似的名次，你就可以获得自动录取资格以及进入荣誉课程的机会。
but you know what? No one told me that getting like 75% on that test is, is, is like in the top 5%. Right. Yeah. Like I took that test in high school, right.
但是你知道吗？没有人告诉我，在这项测试中获得 75% 的分数，是，是，是排在前 5% 左右。对吧。是的。就像我在高中时参加了那个测试一样，对吧。
Before you go to university. And I didn't, uh, my teacher taught me calculus in two days because I was in a semester at school, so I hadn't learned calculus yet. And he's like, you're going to need to know this for this test. So like two days, like here, I'll teach you calculus. I'm like, all right.
在上大学之前。而且我没有，呃——我的老师在两天内教了我微积分，因为我当时在学校的一个学期里，所以我还没学过微积分。他就像是，“你需要在这次测试中了解这个。”所以就像两天时间，就像“来，我教你微积分。”我说：“好吧。”
Put the two from there in the front. Yeah. And then, and I don't know if it's still that way, but at the time, they took marks off if you got the question wrong. Right? It was either you answer it or leave it blank it was better to leave it blank was a zero and if you answered wrong you got marks taken off yeah i i believe that's i mean i always thought it was still uh if you could eliminate
把那里的 2 移到前面。是的。然后，我不知道现在还是不是这样，但在当时，如果你答错了题，他们会扣分。对吧？要么你回答，要么留空。留空得零分会更好，如果你回答错了就会被扣分。是的，我相信是这样的——我的意思是，我一直以为如果能排除掉
guesses yeah if you could eliminate choices still still yeah but i went through that and i'm like god i'm i'm barely gonna you know i don't know calculus also like i'm gonna get like a 70 on this i'm gonna do terrible right so i started guessing on on stuff i'm like like i ended up with like still getting over 50 or something and that was still a high mark right like the brightest people fail this stupid thing and then then i find out later that it's like oh yeah 70 or 75 or whatever like that's an awesome mark and i'm like well why didn't someone tell me this i wouldn't have guessed at all these questions that because you were in bothwell yeah yeah exactly and chatham for high school yeah interesting so it went from one generation of farmers to another,
猜测的话——是的，如果你能排除选项的话，依然如此——依然如此。但我经历了那个过程，我想，天哪，我简直要——你知道，我也不懂微积分——我这次大概只能考个 70 分，我要考砸了，对吧？所以我开始胡乱猜测一些题目，我想——我最后居然还是考了 50 分以上什么的，那仍然是一个很高的分数，对吧？就像最聪明的人也会在这个蠢东西上挂科，然后我后来才发现，哦，对啊，70 分或 75 分或者诸如此类，那是一个了不起的分数，而我想：好吧，为什么没有人告诉我这个？我就不会去瞎猜所有这些问题了，因为你在博斯韦尔。是的，是的，完全正确。为了上高中还在查塔姆。真有趣。所以这是从一代农民传到另一代农民，
and then your dad was in the rodeo, and then you took a hard left or right. Yeah. Farmer rodeo, software rodeo. Yeah, it's kind of funny because my brother and sister still live in the hometown, you know, with a thousand people. My brother still lives on the same property. He's a high school teacher. She was – what's she doing now
然后你爸以前搞过牛仔竞技，接着你的人生来了个急转弯。对啊。农夫牛仔竞技，软件牛仔竞技。对啊，这其实挺搞笑的，因为我哥和我姐还住在老家，你知道的，就那种一千人的小镇。我哥还住在老房子里。他是高中老师。我姐以前——她现在在干嘛来着
she's doing like stuff for united way or something now um uh but yeah they're still like the small town the small town kind of thing and i can still go back there and like just hang out in the in the log house and you know but i am the high tech one of the the family. Do they have any appreciation for, or not appreciation, I should say, but are they aware of the status of your words of wisdom? Every now and then, my sister will send me a link to like, oh my God, you're giving a talk at this thing. I'm like, oh yeah, I give a talk there every year. She's like, what?
她现在好像在联合劝募会之类的地方工作，嗯……不过对，他们依然留在小镇里，过着那种小镇生活。我还是可以回那儿去，在原木小屋里无所事事，你懂的，但我却是家里那个搞高科技的人。他们对你的金玉良言有什么感激之情吗？或者说，不是感激，我应该说，他们知道你在业界的地位吗？每隔一段时间，我姐就会给我发个链接，比如，天哪，你居然在这东西上面做演讲。我说，哦对啊，我每年都在那儿演讲。她就说，什么？
I'm like, oh yeah, I'm giving a keynote there this year kind of thing she's like what don't worry about it it's nothing it's what we do around here but yeah yeah yeah you and I were keynotes of C++ now the same year yeah
我说，哦对啊，我今年在那儿作主旨演讲呢。她就说，什么？别担心，没什么大不了的。这不过是我们这儿常有的事。但对啊对啊对啊，你和我同年在 C++ Now 上作主旨演讲呢
mine obviously was the security keynote I'm just gonna say put that out there yeah i i so want to go back there um i want to i want to yeah we missed you were you there this no i wasn't i didn't want to travel anywhere um i want to keynote there i've had a keynote talk for C++ now probably since the first year I went, like when it was BoostCon. I'm like, I know what I want to talk about. And I haven't written it down, of course,
我那场显然是关于安全的的主旨演讲，我得提一下，把它摆到台面上。对啊，我真的好想回那儿去，我想要——我想要——我们想你了，你当时在那儿吗？这届没有，我不在，我哪儿都不想去。我想要在那儿作主旨演讲，自从我第一次去 C++ Now 以来，大概也就是当它还叫 BoostCon 的时候，我就一直想在那儿作主旨演讲。当时我就想，我知道我想讲什么。当然我一直没写下来，
because why would I write it down except for the week before or something like that? But I've had it in the back of my head for like, what, 10 years now? And then I finally did a keynote, but I was online and I'm like, well, I'm not going to do that talk.
因为除了演讲前的一周左右，我为什么要把它写下来呢？但这个想法我一直在脑子里盘旋了大概，什么，十年了吧？后来我终于做了一个主旨演讲，但我是线上进行的，我想，好吧，我才不讲那个话题呢
I didn't do a different talk. Um, but I still got, I want to do the keynote there. Got to, got to be there. And we also have to, you know,
我讲了另一个话题。嗯，但我还是想，我一定要在那儿作主旨演讲。必须得去，必须得在那儿。而且我们还得，你知道的
you know, Bryce, we've got that plan of doing, uh, doing, uh, yeah, we,
布莱斯，你知道的，我们有个计划，要做个——要做个——对啊，我们
we got plans for special talks at, uh, at C++ now. I, I still, uh, you know, I still have that in the back of my mind. Yeah. Yeah. We got plans for special talks at C++ now. I still have that in the back of my mind. Yeah. So I need to scout out first. I think I need a year of scouting out and planning it,
我们在 C++ Now 上有特别演讲的计划。我，我还是，你知道的，我一直把这事记在心里。对啊。对啊。我们在 C++ Now 上有特别演讲的计划。我一直把这事记在心里。对啊。所以我需要先去侦察一下。我想我需要花一年时间去侦察和策划，
and then the year after that, do it. Oh, is this the – No spoilers. I think I know. Yeah, you mentioned this at some point to me. Yeah. Yeah, I mentioned this. It's the plans. Yeah. At some point to me. Yeah. Yeah, I need help with it too. So I need...
然后再过一年付诸行动。哦，这是那个——没有剧透。我想我知道。对啊，你以前跟我提过这事。对啊，对啊，我提过这事。就是那些计划。对啊。在某个时候跟我提过。对啊，对啊，我也需要这方面的帮忙。所以我需要……
Yeah. It's going to require a staff. Yeah, exactly. Yeah. You need like three or four or five people. It'll be a little hard to record. A little challenging to record. I mean, with...
对啊。这需要一个团队。对啊，没错。对啊。你需要三、四个或者五个人。录制起来会有点难。录制起来有点挑战。我是说，带着……
I'll say, I won't spoil anything, but with drones, it's possible. With drones, anything is possible. Anything is possible with drones. If we had enough drones, we could make it happen. And I'll just let the listener's imagination wander. I know what I wanted to mention. I'm the youngest of the three.
我这么说吧，我不剧透任何东西，但如果有无人机的话，这是可能的。有了无人机，一切皆有可能。有了无人机，一切皆有可能。如果我们有足够的无人机，我们就能实现它。我就让听众们自己去想象吧。我知道我想提什么了。我是三兄妹里最小的。
I've got my brother, sister. I'm the youngest. Computers showed up in our high school when I was in grade 10. My brother was in grade 12. My sister was in grade 13. We had grade 13 back then. And because they were almost out of school, they're like, oh, computers. We're not going to take the computer course, right?
我有个哥哥和一个姐姐。我是老幺。我上高一时，我们高中迎来了电脑。我哥上高三。我姐上高十三。我们那个年代有高十三。因为他们快毕业了，他们就想，哦，电脑。我们才不选电脑课呢，对吧？
So they just didn't get into computers. I was in grade 10. Computers showed up. I'm like, I'm taking a computer course. This is really cool. So it's the dividing line of my – anyone – probably different in every school. But my brother obviously uses computers and everything, but he is not friendly with computers. Whereas I just – I live with him every day, right? And it's just because they just missed the window.
所以他们就没接触电脑。我上高一。电脑来了。我想，我要选一门电脑课。这太酷了。所以这是我人生的一道分界线——每个人——可能每个学校都不一样。我哥当然也用电脑做各种事，但他对电脑并不友好。而我只是——我每天都跟它打交道，对吧？这纯粹是因为他们错过了那个窗口期。
They didn't learn it from the beginning, right? It's amazing how small things like that. Yeah, it makes a difference, right? Yeah. Like if the pandemic had started a year earlier, like probably this podcast, Bryce and I being friends, all of this. Because like my life and career took a different trajectory basically when. I would have found you, Connor.
他们没有从一开始就学，对吧？真奇妙，像这样的小事。对啊，这确实造成了不同，对吧？对啊。就好比如果大流行早一年开始，可能这个播客、我和布莱斯成为朋友，所有这些都会不一样。因为我的人生和职业轨迹基本上在……时发生了改变。我会找到你的，康纳。
There is nothing in the universe that would have kept us apart. Or actually, yeah, we probably would have been friends. But like the C++ Now talk that I initially gave like said a a bunch of stuff, chain reaction, and then I switched to NVIDIA. But like if the pandemic had started 12 months earlier, that conference wouldn't have happened. The talk wouldn't have happened. And who knows? My arch nemesis talk. Oh yeah, that's right.
宇宙中没有什么力量能把我们分开。或者说其实，对啊，我们大概本来就会成为朋友。但我在 C++ Now 最初作的那个演讲说了很多事，引发了一连串反应，然后我跳槽去了英伟达。但如果大流行早 12 个月开始，那个会议就不会举行。那个演讲就不会发生。谁知道呢？我的死敌演讲。哦对，没错。
I forgot. We're arch enemies. Wait, why are you arch enemies? Is it because Connor beat you up for all the awards? Because I wasn't there that year. But they used to call them the Tony Awards because I won them. And then Connor shows up, and he wins even more. Oh, that's because they created a bunch of new ones for me.
我都忘了。我们是死敌。等等，为什么你们是死敌？是因为康纳把你的所有奖项都抢光了吗？因为我那年不在。但他们以前管那些奖叫托尼奖，因为我老得奖。然后康纳出现了，他赢了更多奖。哦，那是因为他们为我设立了一堆新奖项。
Every single award. Yeah. Minus one. But they made up new awards. Like, you know, best award by someone who starts with the letter C or something like that. Like, I don't know. I swear my hand to God, I had nothing to do with the awards process and I had no influence over who got the awards. Like, I know it seems like I must have set that up so that Connor, so that my prediction would come true.
每一个奖。对啊。除了一个。但他们设立了新奖项。比如，你知道的，由名字以 C 开头的人获得的最佳奖项之类的。就像，我不知道。我向上帝发誓，我跟评奖过程一点关系都没有，我也没有影响谁能得奖。就像，我知道这看起来一定是我安排的，好让康纳，好让我的预言成真。
But no, I really just called it. The new award was, and I really liked the idea, was like Best New Speaker Award. Yeah, but he won like Best New Speaker and like Best Speaker and like all the other ones. What was the one award that you didn't win? David Sankel won it. Well, I also didn't win Best Talk when i won all my i i did my post-modern talk there first the first time i did post-modern and it didn't win and that's you know i will never win an award there now because that was it that was my peak well you don't have any well you can't
但并没有，我真的只是瞎猫碰死耗子。新设的那个奖是，而且我真的很喜欢这个主意，就是“最佳新演讲者奖”。对啊，但他赢了“最佳新演讲者”还赢了“最佳演讲者”以及所有其他奖。你没得的是哪个奖？大卫·桑克尔得了那个。好吧，我也没得过“最佳演讲”。当我做我的后现代演讲时，那是我第一次做后现代演讲，然后它没得奖。你知道的，我再也不会在那儿得奖了，因为那就是巅峰了。好吧，你没有什么，好吧，你不能
say that don't tell me that tony i'd. I'm looking forward to the, you know. Oh, the upcoming talk? This from the guy who said that he's not going to give any more C-Post post-talks. Who? You. Oh, yeah. Well, you can't say that on air. I know. I've heard you say that already.
这么说，别这么跟我说，托尼。我很期待那个，你知道的。哦，即将到来的演讲？这话居然出自一个说自己再也不做 C++ 演讲的人之口。谁？你。哦，对啊。好吧，你不能在广播里这么说。我知道。我以前就听你这么说过。
I have an excellent editor. I have an excellent editor. What does me not giving any talks have to do with me not wanting to see tony's uh you've got like two categories of talks there's like the tony tony talks and then there's like tony technical talks and they're both great but like the tony tony talks are like it's like get your popcorn my favorite part about the tony talk is that the one tony talk where there's like where tony like accurately predicts that I'm going to be tweeting the talk. Yeah.
我有一个优秀的编辑。我有一个优秀的编辑。我不做任何演讲，跟我不想看托尼的——有什么关系？你的演讲大概分两类，一种是“托尼的托尼演讲”，还有一种是“托尼的技术演讲”，它们都很棒。但“托尼的托尼演讲”那种感觉就像是，快准备好爆米花吧。关于托尼演讲，我最喜欢的部分就是其中有一场，托尼精准地预测了我要在推特上直播他的演讲。对啊。
Yeah. I did get that right. I do. I do miss a good Tony talk. There will be, there will be some, some fun in my talk coming up. If you notice the,
对啊。我确实猜对了。我的确。我确实挺怀念一场精彩的托尼演讲的。接下来的演讲里，会有一些，会有一些趣味。如果你注意到的话，
did anyone read the abstract? I mean, I did, but I read. I haven't looked at the program. How can you say you read it and don't remember? It's the Beatles. He's the program chair. He has to say you read every abstract.
有人读过摘要吗？我是读了，但我读了。我还没看日程表。你怎么能说你读了却不记得？他是日程委员会主席。他必须说他读过每一篇摘要。
I, as a former prominent program chair, will tell you, you don't read all the abstracts my abstract is a beatles song um parodied you know change change some words there um i'm gonna i'm gonna go i'm gonna go look at look at it now this is why the the talk is called so you want to write a function i can i can just tell you so you want to write a function well you know we all want to change the code oh yeah see that's the thing is i do recall reading this but i don't know the beatles well enough to know that this is a beetle song oh man what are you 12 which one of yous and you're both i mean i the problem is i just don't know lyrics yeah i can sing you a couple like um we'll look up uh revolution revolution and also
我，作为一个前任杰出日程委员会主席，可以告诉你，你根本不会读完所有的摘要。我的摘要是一首披头士的歌，呃，被恶搞了，你知道的，改了一些词。我打算，我打算去，我打算去看一下。这就是为什么这个演讲名叫“所以你想写一个函数”。我可以直接告诉你，所以你想写一个函数，好吧，你知道的，我们都想改变代码。哦对，事情就是这样，我确实记得读过这个，但我对披头士不够熟，不知道这是一首披头士的歌。天哪，你 12 岁吗？你们俩到底是哪个——我的问题是，我就是不了解歌词。对啊，我可以给你唱几句，比如，呃，我们查查，呃，《革命》（Revolution），还有
the problem is is like this is not the first time if you've ever read ben dean's um abstracts he also does these kind of artistic i don't know if they're poems or if they're lyrics yeah um yeah you don't know what to base it off of did did you know that some people don't know dr seuss that's what i learned right like half the world doesn't know like if you're not raised english you might not know dr seuss i guess that's true yeah i mean i we i didn't i knew dr seuss because there was movies but we we didn't we weren't allowed dr seuss in my household what is wrong with you i mean my mother was very very i told a story about my father but my mother let us watch like four television story about my father but my mother let
问题是，这已经不是第一次了。如果你读过本·迪恩的摘要，他也会搞这种具有艺术感的——我不知道它们是诗还是歌词。对啊，对啊，你都不知道该以什么为基础。你知道吗，有些人不知道苏斯博士。这就是我学到的，比如世界上有一半人不知道，如果你不是在英语环境中长大的，你可能不知道苏斯博士。我想确实是这样。对啊，我的意思是，我们没有——我知道苏斯博士是因为有电影，但在我家，我们是不被允许看苏斯博士的。你们到底有什么毛病？我的意思是，我妈非常非常——我讲过我爸的故事，但我妈只让我们看大概四部电视节目——我讲过我爸的故事，但我妈只让我们
us watch like four television shows yeah but dr seuss is the most educational thing ever i mean she would disagree she's wrong anyone out there listening our listener um uh who may be of that age where you're about to have kids and maybe english isn't your first language you want to teach your kids some english dr seuss books i mean also didn't dr seuss get canceled no they they they took out the and not it wasn't canceled the people in charge of dr seuss like the estate or whatever the publishers and stuff they said oh this book looking back like the guy wrote the stuff in the 40s or whenever it was right like culture changes so they're like yeah this book is a little bit let's not publish this one anymore right i see and but all the other books they're great all right i've got i've got
看大概四部电视节目。对啊，但苏斯博士是最具教育意义的东西了。我的意思是，她会不同意，她是错的。所有在听节目的听众朋友们，呃，你们可能正处于那个准备生孩子的年纪，也许英语不是你们的第一语言，你想教孩子们一些英语，苏斯博士的书。我的意思是，苏斯博士不是被取消了吗？没有，他们拿掉了——并不是被取消，是负责苏斯博士版权的人，比如遗产管理方或出版商之类的人说，哦，回过头来看这本书——那家伙是 40 年代还是什么时候写这东西的，对吧？文化在变，所以他们说，好吧，这本书有点那个，我们还是别再出版这本了，对吧？我明白。但所有其他的书都很棒。好吧，我已经把
the beatles revolution up but i'll i'll play it um at a later date i'll'll put a link. That's going to be the outro or the intro. Yeah, we don't take too much concern. Unlike my other podcast, Arraycast, we do not concern ourselves with copyright. Feel free to sue us. It'll be good for our ratings. But remember, if you want to sue this podcast, you've got to sue Connor.
披头士的《革命》找出来了，但我会把它——在晚些时候播放，我会放个链接。那将作为片尾曲或片头曲。对啊，我们不用太担心。不像我的另一个播客 Arraycast，我们不关心版权。尽管来告我们吧。这对我们的收视率有好处。但记住，如果你想告这个播客，你得去告康纳。
Because this is a canadian-based podcast cut it you're fine you're fine you're fine it's canada nobody's gonna come to canada that's true trust me you'll be fine everyone's gonna come to canada because uh your country over there is uh need some help well we're gonna have to have to have you back tony because i feel like we just got started. We just got the introduction out of the way. We lightly talked about functions at one point. We'll talk at the conference or after the conference.
因为这是一个加拿大的播客。切掉，你没事的，你没事的，你没事的，这是加拿大，没人会来加拿大的。那倒是，相信我，你会没事的。每个人都会来加拿大，因为，呃，你们那边的国家，呃，需要一些帮助。好吧，我们得请你再来，托尼，因为我觉得我们才刚开始。我们才刚把引言部分过完。我们刚才稍微聊了一下函数。我们会在会议上或会议之后再聊。
Oh, yeah. But yeah, we'll do a live recording in T-minus 24 days for us, 17 days for the listener. Actually, at this point. It's after. It's probably past. Conference is over. It's probably past the CPP North. That was a good, man. This is one of my favorite conferences.
哦，对啊。不过对，我们会在 24 天倒计时后进行一次现场录制，对我们来说是 24 天，对听众来说是 17 天。实际上，到这个时候。已经结束了。可能已经过了。会议已经结束了。可能已经过完 CPP North 了。那真是一场好会议，老兄。这是我最喜欢的会议之一。
It was so good. You guys did an awesome job. I think my talk went well. I think all the talk. And that thing that happened. Oh, that thing. That was great. That crazy thing.
太棒了。你们干得太棒了。我觉得我的演讲很顺利。我觉得所有的演讲都很好。还有发生的那件事。哦，那件事。太棒了。那件疯狂的事。
All the keynotes. Kate's keynote's always awesome. Sean. Like, everyone. That was... You guys did an awesome job. That was one of the best... It might be my new favorite conference.
所有的主旨演讲。凯特的永远都那么棒。肖恩的。就像，每个人。太棒了……你们干得太棒了。那是最好的会议之一……这可能是我新的最爱会议了。
Wait, what are we talking about? C++ North. Oh. Oh. I'm like, Kate wasn't at C++ now. What's going on? I did not register what was happening there for a solid 20 seconds. Keep up, man.
等等，我们在说什么？C++ North。哦。哦。我当时想，凯特又不在C++。怎么回事？我足足愣了20秒才反应过来发生什么事了。跟上节奏，老兄。
Keep up. Yes, it was great. And like Bryce said, that thing that happened. That thing that happened. That was awesome. I was literally like, I was having FOMO because I thought you guys were talking about some other conference.
跟上节奏。是的，太棒了。就像布莱斯说的，那件事发生了。那件事发生了。太棒了。我简直有种恐错过（FOMO）的感觉，因为我以为你们在谈论别的什么会议。
I was like, what happened? I'm not in the know. It's the best conference. Why didn't you tell me? All right, Tony. Thanks for coming on. We will see you in T-minus. Yeah.
我当时想，发生了什么？我怎么不知道。这是最好的会议。你为什么不告诉我？好了，托尼。谢谢你来参加。我们倒计时再见。是的。
Yeah. A couple of weeks or we saw you in the past at this point. It was great. It was nice seeing you again in person. Thanks for listening.
是的。几周后，或者此时我们已经通过过去相见了。太棒了。很高兴能再次见到你本人。谢谢收听。
We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
希望你喜欢并度过美好的一天。本集暂无评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。